oh wow
nbcsports.com
sixers should have higher than tony
instead
who wrote that i i don't know
i don't know
tom haberstro is is that your fine work
that would be my calm it just went up uh
this afternoon and yes i do think mike
d'antoni would have been better for this
team
because that's right take the floor take
the floor tom
because this team needs shooting around
joel embiid and ben simmons and who else
is going to convince ben simmons to
shoot jumpers than the best offensive
minded coach
in this era mike d'antoni should have
been the head coach i don't think doc is
a bad hire but i would prefer mike
d'antoni because at least elton brand
the general manager would surround those
guys with shooters instead of al horford
uh and other guys who don't have any
business being around two non-shooting
big so i think that was gonna be a huge
thing in this talk with mike d'antoni
and doc rivers is how do we get the best
out of these two two superstars i think
mike d'antoni understands you gotta have
shooters
mike you want to go you want me to go uh
there's a lot there
there's another you go first you go
first you go okay okay couple of things
a couple of things stroke come on thanks
bro okay all right all right just
processing what you're saying here so
number one
uh
why do we want to encourage ben simmons
to shoot that's number one until until
he actually can number two
i think if i'm out on brandon doc rivers
maybe i don't run the same system but as
best i can i'm going to try to surround
these two super these two stars
with shooters if that's possible given
the construction of that roster so let's
strictly on a theme of shooting
i i think you can still
try to tinker with the roster with doc
rivers as the coach and i think he knows
he needs to but in terms of ben simmons
like
who would want ben simmons shooting more
what am i missing there
well we don't know if he's a bad shooter
because he won't shoot i mean we haven't
seen it exactly so i think when ben
simmons when ben simmons says no to
brett brown about yo i'm not i'm i'm not
going to shoot maybe for
you know years down the road i don't
need to shoot i'm already an all-star at
23 years old but when mike d'antoni
who's been the architect of some of the
best offenses in nba history is telling
you maybe he's going to listen up and i
will say this
i don't think doc rippers is a bad coach
i think actually the idea that he was
fired in in la is asinine to me because
i feel like people make so much of a big
deal about him blowing 3-1 leads and it
drives me crazy i think blowing a 3-1
lead is the most overrated talking point
in sports because you have to win three
games in a series to blow it it's almost
that the way we talk about top rivers
and him blowing 3-1 leads it's almost
like we'd rather him be swept like
seriously i think people out there the
way they dunk and clown on doc rivers
for blowing three one leads you would
think that they don't want him to win
any games in that series that would be
preferable and you know how many times
doc rivers has ever been swept in a
postseason series
16 post seasons 29 playoff series he's
been swept zero times you can't say that
about pop rick carlisle terry stotts or
mike bundles or all of those coaches
been swept multiple times doc rivers has
zero i don't think he's the best
but i just think people are so in love
with the clowning on doc rivers for
blowing 3-1 leads it removes any sort of
perspective on him as being a good coach
you